depuis le début de l'invasion russe en
ukraine de nombreuses personnalités se
sont engagés pour venir en aide aux
ukrainiens qu'un pays qui se révoltent
et qui ne tombera pas madonna céline
dion angelina jolie si certains ont
diffusé des images de paix en appelant
aux dons d'autres se sont rendus
directement sur le terrain c'est le cas
de l'acteur sean penn qui a passé
plusieurs mois sur le sol ukrainien pour
tourner un documentaire
s'il est revenu récemment l'acteur songe
déjà à y retourner mais cette fois ci en
prenant les armes si vous avez été en
ukraine le fait de se battre vous
traverse forcément l'esprit l'autre jour
je me suis mis à penser à prendre les
armes contre la russie l'acteur a même
précisé qu'il pourrait y est allé son
gilet pare balles alors sean penn de
prendre les armes pour aller en ukraine
qui pouvait faire pareil
en tout cas je trouve honnête parce que
c'est vrai que beaucoup de courage pour
courage pour lui dire non mais quand
elle a remarqué ce qui a dit que c'est
insupportable d'hypocrisie et de
démagogie déjà il en ukraine pas par
solidarité mais pour faire un dock pour
se faire mousser et ensuite il dit le
songe à aller en ukraine vas-y mais qui
est personne te retiens et arrête de
culpabiliser les gens se lassent et
sous-entendu moi j'ai le courage d'y
aller et pas vous et aussi des gens qui
mènent des actions et qui ne le montre
pas donc je pense qu'il ferait mieux d'y
aller sans le montrer plutôt que de ne
pas y aller et le dire par tous et
sean finn geipel il a choisi il ya 62
ans
mais la seule chose c'est qu'ils y
étaient avant la guerre il n'est pas
allé parce qu'il y avait la guerre il
était avant on est bon qui se trouve à
être sur place quand il ya eu la guerre
non mais c'est beau de effectivement
d'être engagé comme ça mondialement et
ce qui se passe chez nos voisins mais
mais très concrètement aller en guerre
en fait on n'est pas préparé c'est pour
ça qu'il faudrait il faudrait vraiment
que le service militaire se remettre en
place en fait parce que nous les jeunes
et les jeunes garçons et touba on sait
pas tenir les armes on ne sait pas avoir
une endurance physique et/ou faudrait
remettre 100 qui a fait son service
gilles préjean pas volé le mois
d'août et les lumières des voeux faire
la guerre mais je voudrais pas du tout
vous étés l'armée vous moi j'étais
exemptés parce que j'ai
commencé à travailler à 16 ans et à
l'époque je travaillais énergie et si
jamais je partais faire mon service
militaire mon risque était de par
trouver de boulot on retourne
réforme et moi je suis pk et je me suis
fait vous êtes des planqués à moi
j'étais j'ai fait l'armée et j'ai
d'ailleurs je me suis beaucoup marré
parce que j'étais secrétaire des
aumôniers des homonymes
la colonelle il y avait un pasteur et un
catho et plus à savoir ce qu on a rigolé
parce que d'abord il se péter la gueule
tous les jours
modération l'alcool ne seraient pas
d'accord je fais des conneries
modération d'organes se péter la gueule
après je vais ramener faisait la sieste
et je mets en revanche je m'occupais de
leurs affaires courantes qui était quand
même assez importante parce qu on allait
sur toutes les bases aériennes c'était
un ami de l'air c'était génial moi j'ai
une année magnifique et j'habitais la
bagnole et j'allais me baigner au pyla
il a des étoiles dans les yeux quand il
pas
vraiment oui vous êtes c'est pour vous
faire re réformer p4 vous ça veut dire
que je suis apte à tous et des coûts
d'accès très simple ils ont déjà repéré
routard alors j'ai préparé la chose j'ai
été voir un psychiatre pendant pendant
un an et en fait je n'ai pas d'une
psychiatre que je voulais me faire
réformer et donc je me j'avais préparé
c'est que des bouquins jusqu'au bout
j'étais en fait j'étais un bon étudiant
dont j'ai travaillé mon personnage de
deux banques on va pas se mentir et donc
quand je lui ai parlé il a été dit que
ce garçon ne doivent surtout pas faire
l'armée donc un jour il m'a dit mais
elle vous fait l'armée libanais dit
alors je vous fais un petit courrier ne
bougeait pas j'ai tendu le courrier aux
militaires qui m'ont dit ne bougeait pas
et ça a duré deux secondes balles à je
ne sais toujours pas ce qui venant
d'être mais visiblement on va les faire
attention à moi à vous avez été pendant
un an chez merci pour pas faire voilà
voilà dhouib ont annoncé nguyen hong
hanh on and on and on and on allait
les romans que fifa un mois en immersion
à saint maixent j'ai adoré le temps que
les instructeurs étaient magnifiques
merci pour cette remarque extrêmement
intéressante